vishi Russia this is the sound of Riga
one of Europe's new cultural capitals
choirmaster instead of skis is
rehearsing in an unusual spot at a
butcher's counter Riga will ring in its
big year next week at its famous Central
Market there'll be a song every hour on
the hour sales people will sing their
life stories the venue has made for some
odd situations it's challenging for me
when I first said to my singers that we
are going to sing of course all the
vegetarians said no no no no no Regas
residents will get a chance to tell
their stories here the building was
constructed over 80 years ago it's five
pavilions were built from parts of old
German Zeppelin hangars that's just a
small part of the city's history once a
proud member of the Hanseatic League
Riga often had to fight to maintain its
independence
the National Museum has organized an
exhibition of East European art some of
the works are from countries that
briefly enjoyed independence between the
two world wars including Latvia that
later fell under Soviet rule the idea is
to reconcile the country's past with its
present via show anatoly sharij coffins
of course we're looking back at our
history and we've concentrated in the
past 100 years 100 years after the first
world war after Latvia became
independent we want to show that despite
this history were also a very modern
city that's looking to the future stars
int that's what the exhibition entitled
1914 wants to highlight the new national
library is a piece of modernity in the
old city designed by us Latvian goona
bill cuts it now needs to be filled with
books that are currently held in various
collections around the city some 7,000
locals are going to help
that's why local librarians are hard at
work next week a chain of book lovers
will be formed people will hand the
books to each other to get them from one
building to the next in the very end of
this process people told us when you
moved is a new library please call us we
will come to help you
during 2014 there'll be hundreds of
events and exhibitions as we go shows
itself off to the world and celebrates
its prestigious status as a European
Capital of Culture